working in there
all right on the edge hang in there
yeah very nice finds a fairway
take the water out of play
and we'll find out
very nice that's a statement right there
look at the darkness of the grain there
that's going to kick it to his right
that's where the grain's going first you
can see it moving to his right and then
straightens up
it doesn't look like he's using that
slope way to the right he's going to
just let it break softly
there you go start to cross nice shot
shot
that's why he does so well in the majors
he is so solid on these that this one
should go right in the center
it does
[Music]
keeps cutting
don't know
all right not that bad i can see it just
covered it's a good spot absolutely
that's all it's just bunker yeah no it's
just on the middle
uh i miss hit it but the tough thing on
that first because it's still sticking
it's got enough height to catch the
front
that's bouncing that's literally going
to be middle of the green it's actually
really good
wow
safety
yeah good job
nice very nice all right there's to go
three up
oh it's pretty good oh
brooks kepca pours it in wow
any questions
tell you what i think that should be all
right absolutely on the green
still
rolling back getting a little bit
i think it needs to sit i'm not sure
oh wow sit where should it dead right
next to the park
yeah get by cash
where is this on the pga tour man i mean
he plays so
so good right now man this is kind of
like my major right now right
it did not bank right
brooks good job man
enjoy playing
capital one is a match now we have a
couple of challenger holders ahead of us
so congratulations to brooks kepca
version five of capital one's the match
thanks